[Música]
muchas veces escuchamos que los sucesos
que te marcan de pequeño son los que
definirán tu comportamiento a lo largo
de tu vida
yo soy el ama y bueno crece como
ingeniero agrónomo de la universidad y
me tocaba trabajar en campo
trabaja en una empresa peruana muy
conocida
y esta empresa se caracteriza por
producir frutas y hortalizas de muy alta
calidad tu es una de estas y son
hermosas la verdad son muy bonitas pero
detrás de estas características hay una
historia y yo fui testigo es historia
aún recuerdo con dos jeans y camisa bajo
un tórrido sol
y bueno y una de mis primeras primeras
misiones en el trabajo fue supervisar
una aplicación de insecticida orgánico
está muy bueno para que sea tu primera
actividad y bueno yo lo tomé
comenzó en la aplicación
comenzó la aplicación todo iba muy bien
la aplicación y recorrió el campo
posterior a que culminarán la aplicación
y me di con la sorpresa de algo que
alguna vez había leído
al pie de las plantas había miles y
miles de insectos moribundos en ese
momento yo me di cuenta de algo
que la humanidad vea los insectos en su
mayoría como enemigos
la sociedad nos ha formado así ya sean
medios de comunicación diferentes tipos
de redes pero realmente esto comienza
desde la revolución verde donde la
agricultura a gran escala toma fuerza y
la aparición de insecticidas para
erradicar plagas aparecen con ellos
bueno y es una oportunidad perfecta para
poderme dirigir a los directores
rectores diferentes cabezas de
universidades y colegios para que se
detengan en enseñarnos erradicar
insectos solamente también enséñanos a
aprovechar a los insectos para el
beneficio de la humanidad beneficios del
punto de vista de la cosmética nutrición
medicina infinidad de beneficios
yo reto a las personas que me están
escuchando
a que me digan 4 insectos 4 insectos que
consideren positivos para la sociedad y
yo estoy muy seguro que van a poder
decir 3 no más
comencemos le voy a leer la mente las
abejas las mariquitas y las mariposas y
el cuarto estoy seguro que no van a
encontrar un cuarto insecto porque
realmente nos crían de esta manera de
ver de manera negativa a los insectos en
la sociedad y por eso yo he destinado
parte de mi vida y lo que viene de ella
a reivindicar el nombre de los insectos
en la sociedad básicamente la sociedad
peruana los insectos se caracterizan
porque son una fuente sostenible de
diferentes tipos de recursos podemos
encontrar por ejemplo que son una fuente
increíble de proteína increíble de
nutrientes y no solamente lo digo yo
sino que lo dice una entidad a nivel
mundial que es la fao la afa en la
entidad mundial
pionera en estos temas de alimentación y
la fao misma no se ha comentado nos dice
que los insectos son recomendables para
el consumo humano hemos llegado hasta el
tope de insostenibilidad de nuestras
proteínas
por ejemplo ahorita voy a mencionar
alguna pero estamos tan insostenibles en
todo esto que la fao misma con tal
calibre a nivel mundial nos recomienda
humanidad consuman insectos
prácticamente
por esto yo lo que veo es que tenemos
algunas crianzas muy conocidas como por
ejemplo en la carne de res que para
producir un kilo de carne de res según
sea una cantidad excesiva de agua se usa
entre 15.000 a 22 mil litros de agua por
ejemplo para producir un insecto llamado
tenebrio molitor nosotros usamos 2
litros de agua y el insecto duplica en
cantidad de proteína a la carne teniendo
en cuenta todo esto
nos arriesgamos y nos lanzamos a
producir nosotros como empresa
insectos en laboratorio insectos
comestibles para humanos dentro de un
laboratorio hemos criado un insecto
llamado ver metí luces e insectos como
los grillos y el tenebrio molitor que es
el que destaca entre estos
particularmente los insectos que he
mencionado si bien a simple vista no son
muy agradables comparado por ejemplo con
una mariposa multicolor pero son
infinitamente nutritivos hay compuestos
activos que se pueden sacar de ellos hay
diferentes subproductos
entonces en verdad darnos cuenta de ello
yo creo que ya llegó el momento
particularmente quiero comentarles acá
una anécdota con un compañero mi socio
nosotros iniciamos esta empresa que le
mencionó con mi hermana raisa lama y con
mi socio renzo cateriano renzo al inicio
él es ingeniero industrial
pero es un ingeniero industrial que
nunca se imaginó trabajar con insectos
el al inicio no tenía esa capacidad para
agarrar a los insectos a primera mano no
se atrevía
renzo fue instruyéndose mes por mes le
tomó definitivamente un poco un poco de
tiempo y finalmente un día me dice
eduardo estoy preparado para esto y yo
procedo a ponerle medio millar de larvas
en la palma de sus manos ahí me di
cuenta de algo de algo muy importante
que la información derrumba ámbitos
bueno y ahora tenemos millones y
millones de insectos creándose en el
laboratorio pero como vamos a hacer para
que estos insectos sean consumidos por
los por las personas es muy difícil
tratar de incorporar a insectos en la
dieta de las personas porque no están
acostumbradas
yo no puedo ofrecerle por ejemplo medio
kilo de larvas para algún tipo de comida
es casi imposible que lo consuman
entonces qué cosas fue lo que hicimos lo
que hicimos fue lo siguiente hemos
creado la primera marca peruana de
productos elaborados a base de insectos
esta marca ofrece barras proteína y las
barras de proteínas son el primer
peldaño de una escalera de diferentes
productos la idea es pasar de barras de
proteínas a productos mucho más visuales
de esta manera a normalizar el consumo
de insectos en la sociedad peruana
sucede que la aceptación de este
producto ha sido increíble padres de
familia consumiendo los niños madres
deportistas aficionados y profesionales
personas que trabajan desde casa en
verdad ha sido bastante exitoso este
producto y eso es lo siendo orgullo
porque sabemos que este es la manera de
cómo ellos están iniciando normalizando
y adaptando para el futuro de la
alimentación
ahora para finalizar quisiera
preguntarles algo continúan viendo los
insectos de la misma manera yo sé que no
y ahora les quiero pedir a todos ya
todas sus ayuda
ayúdenme a que los niños vuelvan a tener
esa capacidad de asombro hacia la
naturaleza porque en un futuro no muy
lejano los insectos serán la proteína
que comerán sus hijos muchas gracias